this you have to see this story is an
example of
wasted activism and wasted energy
so many people in this country in many
countries but we're talking about this
one
aren't involved in anything going on
around them they don't know what's going
on
they're checked out they don't get
involved in anything
in their communities whether the
communities are their immediate
surroundings the state federal politics
whatever
some people do get involved but they get
involved
pushing for all of the wrong things and
that's what this is an example of in
yukon oklahoma
a school board meeting was interrupted
by anti-masters
multiple times each with an outburst
more weaponized than delusional than the
one
that came before it board members in
uconn
voted to keep masks on students for the
rest of the semester now how long is
that
it's only another 11 days and i'm gonna
get to that in a little bit
and it makes sense to keep students
wearing masks because none of the
students are vaccinated other than the
stray
17 or 18 year old senior at the
elementary school
none of them are vaccinated at the
middle school none of them are
vaccinated and at the high school
almost none of them are vaccinated
there's going to be some flexibility on
the masking policy for the younger
students but 50
anti-massacres showed up at this meeting
and shockingly some of them were given
huge rounds of applause
for their anti-mask rants here is one
such woman
screaming that this is not about covid
this is about control
and the crowd goes wild they're cheering
this insanity
[Applause]
people are applauding what appears to be
a demonic possession uh you know
heretofore i did not believe in demonic
possession
but this video is making me second-guess
myself maybe demonic possession is a
thing
this video almost made me believe in
astrology it's so nuts like if someone
came to me
and said david i know it you can't
understand this video but i can
this video is explained because this
woman is a scorpio and scorpios behave
like this
this is so nuts i almost would believe
an astrological explanation because
nothing else is making sense
if you were watching you might have seen
the police start to slowly approach this
woman
as the rant was winding down is there a
silver
lining of some kind here can we say that
hey at least she's showing enthusiasm
about education policy no of course i'm
kidding
this is a tragedy i actually looked at
the yukon
public schools calendar the last day of
school is thursday may 20th
after today they have 11 school days
left and this woman
and others are taking time out of their
days
and going crazy about 11 days of masks
in school for unvaccinated children
during a global pandemic
just imagine if they use their activism
and their energy for good instead of
evil like imagine what good these people
could do
if they were fighting for like anything
other than fighting against 11 more days
of masking in school
we would live in a different world if
that energy
was put to something worthwhile and if
you needed any evidence to support
teachers
being paid more by the way this video
would be exhibit a because these are the
parents that these teachers are dealing
with now by the way
at one point in the video the woman also
screams that her son is four years old
from what i've read the mask mandate
only partially even applies to the
four-year-old
so she's out there protesting against
just 11 more days of masks
in the fall probably there won't be a
need for masks
assuming vaccination continues and as
far as it applies to her four-year-old
it's part of the day 11 days
of masks it's a tragedy of education
it's a tragedy of culture and it is
horrifying in absolutely every way we
can imagine and when we talk about oh
wow
biden needs a new strategy for
vaccinating people because there's so
many anti-vaxxers
it's the same type of people that would
show up and rant like this
on camera about 11 days of masks it's a
tragedy
it's a real tragedy and we'll have some
more clips from this deranged and
hair-brained meeting
on our instagram you can follow the
david pakman show on instagram
at davidpakmanshow you can follow me on
instagram
david.pakman and we'll be back right
after this